but first to the case of Daniel Perry in
Texas Perry's an army Sergeant who was
driving for Uber in Austin during the
2020 black lives matter riots a mob
surrounded his car in the middle of the
street and we know this because parts of
what happened next are captured on video
one rioter closed in and raised his
AK-47 in Perry's Direction Perry
responded to the threat to his life shot
and killed the man in self-defense
the local D.A saw us backed
charged Perry with murder for that and
last week Perry was convicted
Daniel Perry's family in shock crying
over the fact that he had just been
convicted of murder for killing
protester Garrett Foster in 2020. Perry
himself
unable to hide his emotion
hugging his attorney as he cried is
there a
the state wasting no time I'm asking the
Divinity remanded into custody
Perry was turned over into the custody
of the Travis County Sheriff's Office
handcuffed instantly
so you're not allowed to defend yourself
against BLM rioters even when they point
a rifle at you that's the lesson but of
course that lesson is incompatible with
Justice and so to his credit the
governor of Texas Greg Abbott has
announced that he will pardon Daniel
Perry it's a little more complicated in
Texas Perry uh is behind bars tonight
but the governor has instructed the
pardons board to work on an expedited
review that's required by law in Texas
in order for a pardon to occur but he is
pardoning this man that is obviously the
right thing to do George Soros can't pay
for people to put his political
opponents in jail and then have a
republican Governor ignore it it's
outrageous
but of course Democrats think he should
be convicted of murder because one of
their voters got killed now everyone
involved in this was the same color
white
but of course Greg Abbott is a racist
for some reason for pardoning Perry
watch this
I understand what happened is doing so
much of this here go back to Galveston
Texas and you're going to find out what
happened remember he was in Texas the
black folks were kept into slavery uh
over two years after they had been freed
this is what we're dealing with in this
country this is why you ended up having
a black lives matter protest in the
first place seemingly the Republicans do
not believe in being hard on crime when
it comes to certain folk right seemingly
they only want to be hard on crime when
they are poor when they are black when
they are brown if Daniel Perry gets
pardoned for murder in Texas it'll
really only be because he killed the
right kind of person the person that
could right Wingers don't care about
that is a black lives matter protester
but the guy who was shot was white like
this is insane and by the way
Congressman Clyburn does not get the
credit that he deserves for being
completely dishonest ignorable and also
totally corrupt was promoting his
daughter for government jobs
so the Texas pardons board is now
reviewing Daniel Perry's pardon they're
not watching MSNBC we hope but we wanted
to speak to one of the few people who
knows tonight what Daniel Perry is going
through sitting
Behind Bars
for defending himself Kyle Rittenhouse
lived that experience he joins us
tonight call right now thank you so much
for coming on thank you for having me
Tucker
so here you have a guy I don't think
there's really any debate the protester
who was killed raised a rifle at him is
exactly what happened uh with you how do
you think Daniel Perry feels tonight
sitting in jail
I can only imagine he's probably sitting
there wondering what happened he
defended himself he knows what he did
was right you have a man with an AK-47
and over 120 rounds of ammo on his
person
dress for dress for War as some people
might say with the rifle strapped the
AK-47 raising it towards Daniel Perry
who was in flip-flops and Beach shorts
carrying a revolver
and nobody wants to talk about that
nobody wants to mention that he was
armed I see a lot of reports just saying
he's he fired indiscriminately into a
crowd and he drove into a bunch of
rioters they don't want to talk about
how he was swarmed his how his car was
swarmed with a bunch of rioters trying
to attack him
as he was driving for Uber I mean the
least powerful person in our society
attacked by one of the worst people in
our society who's out there rioting as
in your case you were trying to defend a
used car lot and the child a convicted
child molester tried to kill you and
they took the convicted child molester's
side do you see parallels here
absolutely and you see the double
standard in this case they people aren't
talking about the fact of the person the
second person who attacked Daniel Perry
by one after after sergeant Daniel Perry
defended himself against Garrett Foster
he was then shot at
um three times by a person who was never
charged by the Travis County's County
D.A somebody who reckons recklessly
fired a slew of shots
who
um at Daniel Perry's car and they don't
want to talk about that they don't want
to talk about the recklessness of that
and they don't want to charge him it's a
double standard it's not okay
he fired three shots in the middle of a
city but that's totally fine uh okay
Kyle Rittenhouse thank you for adding to
our knowledge of the story appreciative
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight